hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series the hanger-on people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully some of their their values
that way of thinking their mindsets kind
of seep into us to help us become the
best version of ourselves so today we're
going to learn from Tim Ferriss on
creating the 4-hour body as always if
Tim says something that really really
deeply resonates with you please leave
in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well the 4-hour body is
really meant to be a
choose-your-own-adventure guide to the
human body a hacker's guide to improving
every facet of your physical appearance
and performance whether that's ultra
endurance superhuman strength rapid
fat-loss
sleep sex you name it it covers it all
and for every chapter I did experiments
on myself and also tested all the
science the best science in the field
with as many as 200 test subjects this
video will show you some of the results
and some of the findings so how did you
get from the 4-hour workweek to the
4-hour body so it seems like a complete
non sequitur but the reality is the
4-hour workweek just gave me permission
to write this book the 4-hour body which
is a much clearer reflection of my my
deepest obsession which is physical
tracking so I've recorded just about
every workout in all details since age
18 or so including food logs everything
you can possibly imagine
but just explain a little more detail
what does that mean every time you meet
the meal you write it down these days
that's true in some cases that means
that I would put let's say a medical
device an implant into my side and track
my blood glucose 24/7 and correlate it
to the foods that I eat but if you were
to visit my house for example there's
very little about time management in my
house which is what most people
associate me with but my entire kitchen
my living room it looks like an ER I
mean I have medical devices galvanic
skin response meters you leave it
because looking at the data I gather the
data and look at the patterns I can
figure out which meals make me fat I can
figure out which meals I should eat
before working out to hit personal
records and by deconstructing things in
the same way that people associate me
with the 4-hour workweek and
deconstructing work
you can do things like my father for
example sixty-five years old he lost
close to 90 pounds of fat gained about
30 pounds of muscle and did it with very
very small changes so the book is really
intended to be a hacker's guide to the
human body
why is bodies so important to you
because it is either the force
multiplier for performance it can either
be the greatest performance enhancer or
the greatest handicap and there's an
anecdote that I'm fond of telling that
was told to me by a friend of mine about
Richard Branson so he was visiting
Richard Branson on Necker Island and at
some point there was a group of 20
people potential icons and business and
one of the questions came up how do you
become most productive and Richard
Branson sat back thought for a second
and he said work out as I said was work
out so he started every day by swimming
around Necker Island and he said by
working out I gained an additional three
to four productive hours per day and I
think that in Silicon Valley where we
are right now and elsewhere there are a
lot of people who have accepted this
partial completeness their kick ass as
an employee or as a CEO they're
incredibly good at everything except for
something physically related and they
just accept that being overweight or
being too skinny or being slow whatever
it might be is genetically fixed and in
most cases it's not fixed at all so I'd
like to provide the tools for people to
change those things very quickly and
that was one of the goals of the book
and I remember very early on in the
4-hour workweek what what triggered my
conviction that I had had to write this
was an interview with Clive Thompson of
Wired and we were joking around in the
preamble before the interview and I said
that the two fears of modern man could
be boiled down to too much email and
getting fat and I think that's pretty
accurate
and but people view getting fat is
completely unavoidable and I don't think
it's true
so the guiding tenets for all of this is
whenever you find yourself on the side
of majority it's time to pause and
reflect so the the best way meaning the
most effective way the most efficient
way is seldom what you find in best
practices that are widely known this is
as true for ultra endurance running 50
100 kilometres hundred miles
it is for language learning I'm going to
cover just four first principles because
it would take far too long to go through
the various tactics and details but
these principles our guiding principles
that are a flexible they can be they can
certainly be applied not only to
changing your physical body which is the
bedrock of everything else so as a force
multiplier you can even either improve
your performance everywhere else
business relationships by improving your
body or you can do the opposite these
can also be applied like I said to your
startups or to your company's the
minimum effective dose in the context of
exercise and diet is treating both of
those things like a drug so if someone
prescribes you a drug you're given a
specific dose for a specific outcome if
you have less than that dose you don't
get the desired result more than that
dose and you have side effects so
striving to test by gathering data which
need not be complicated what the minimum
effective dose is and that can be very
very little so this is Tracy again at
the bottom of a kettlebell swing and she
lost like I said 120 pounds on the
right-hand side you have an example of
what I would call a slow carb meal and a
slow carb meal this has become popular
among world-class tennis players among
others there's a big piece on it just in
the last few days really just eliminates
white starches and and carbohydrates for
a period of six days out of every week
it also avoids fruit which is very
controversial because of fructose and
how it's converted by the liver in any
case losing 20 20 to 30 pounds in a
given month in the first month is not
unusual at all and that's primarily fat
so here are a few sample meds
all right minimum effective doses so
five minutes forget about 20 minutes
we're doing one set of kettlebell swings
50 to 75 total repetitions with a
maximum weight three times per week five
minutes the second if you want to lose
body fat it's very very easy to do the
only change you have to start with and I
always recommend starting with one
change is 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes of waking up really easy to
remember you don't change anything else
just change that my dad went from
roughly 5 pounds of average fat loss per
month to almost 19 pounds just by making
that change that's the only change so 30
grams could be a number of hard-boiled
eggs it could be whey protein as an
example oh yes so the clitoris let's
talk about the clitoris
1 to 2 p.m. on the clitoris this is the
reason my book was pulled off the
shelves of Costco by the way in the
United States have some very graphic
sexual chapters I'll cover this very
briefly and then it could be homework
men are pretty clumsy animals so I like
to offer this flitters from the male
perspective one to two o'clock is where
it's going to be most sensitive all
right so just practice please it'll save
everyone a lot of grief 90 to 120
seconds of tension for most muscles what
does this mean this means that rather
than looking at changes in muscle and
believe me just about everything that
you want to change related your body's
going to relate to muscle or fashio
which connect everything slow cadence
movement so you take a weight that
allows you to reach failure where you
can't move any further between 90 and
120 seconds that means five seconds up
much slower than this five seconds down
with maximum weight to failure once per
week that's it that's all you need it's
like hitting a microwave one minute high
for boiling water that's it you need the
prescription you don't necessarily need
the how-to and then lastly about 1200
words for conversational fluency this
can be applied to other things all right
could be applied to viral coefficients
could be applied to many many other
things but striving to find the minimum
effective dose is very very important to
avoid any type of resource waste the
extremes inform the mean not vice-versa
on the left you see garden shears has
anyone here seen the movie objectified
okay we have a few people I highly
recommend that everyone else see this
movie objectified it was created by the
filmmaker who produced Helvetica about
the type font it's a wonderful movie
about design and everyday life and frog
design and we have frog design here is
featured at one point because a client
comes in to discuss with with them
garden shears and they say well a client
might come in and say our average user
is a middle-aged woman she's this height
this way this many years old and the
response from frog design was we don't
care about your average user we want the
extreme use cases and if we can account
for those extreme use cases let's say
paraplegic and then maybe a bodybuilder
who can't brush his own teeth because
his arms are too big whatever those
might be once you solve for those
extreme use cases the middle takes care
of itself
all right in many cases but not
vice-versa and an example from one of my
experiments I didn't have video of this
because I was too occupied
but you can see a number of syringes
there I flew stem cell growth factor
over from Israel
combine that with human growth hormone
actually technically igf-1 along with
many other things including a base of my
own blood this is very interesting I had
my blood taken out and then it was spun
in a special centrifuge to take out all
the growth factors concentrated and then
use it the base for this cocktail then
this was injected locally into sites of
injury whether that was dislocations I'd
had surgeries I had and I was able to
reverse about 95% of my so-called
permanent injuries in the span of six
months I don't recommend that you do
that necessarily but I did find that
using Prolotherapy which is simply sugar
water in effect dextrose in a saline
solution could achieve nine out of ten
times the same effect and that is
something that I would encourage people
who have let's say tennis elbow to
actually look into tracking and loss
aversion is more important than how to
so I recall once in Silicon Valley very
good friend of mine I won't mention him
by name but the CEO of a very well known
company said look I don't want the story
I'm really busy he said look I just want
to lose abdominal fat I want a six-pack
give me the index card with the bullet
points of what I need to do okay sure
so I gave him the index card and I did
the same thing for about a half a dozen
CEOs and the success rate was zero the
success rate was zero because giving a
prescription the how-to isn't enough you
need to set yourself up from a
behavioral psychological standpoint to
fail your proof the change that you want
it's very easy to explain what I mean by
that tracking will beat a prescription
so if you were to take and this is very
true if you look at the research of BJ
Fogg at this Stanford persuasion lab as
an example or just about anywhere else
if you were to take two groups all right
so here's Group A right down the aisle
group B group A you guys all get
personal trainers all right but you have
to wander into your local gym and find a
personal trainer and then group B all I
want you to do let's assume we're
talking about fat loss is take your
iPhone or your smartphone take a
photograph of every meal before you eat
it every snack before you to every drink
before you drink it this group I vote
will have more success more compliance
and more ultimate fat loss and tracking
when you look at it is what to account
for and that's called the flash diet
cover in a second loss aversion is very
important we're very keen at least in
the United States we like to focus on
positive psychology and positive
reinforcement rewards game dynamics that
reward us and I would offer at least if
you look at the literature that shame
humiliation all of these things are very
very powerful in fact more so than the
first group and you should use those
it's a it's a fact not liking it isn't
going to change it so you may as well
leverage it to your advantage in the way
you can do that is by using bets so
let's say a small wager among four
people five people who each contribute
money that's how Tracy lost 120 pounds
or it could be something as simple as a
public display public accountability
using a wiki for that and I've seen this
used for people who could never lose
weight never gained weight using that
public accountability all of a sudden
produces an incentive to change your
behavior if you don't do your job at
your job you get fired if you don't do
your job and you fail on a diet
typically nothing happens so if anybody
out there wants to design a gym here's
what I'd recommend and this is based on
Yale research is you charge everyone 400
dollars a month and then for every visit
to the gym they get 25 back and if they
don't hit their goals after 3 months
when they sign up they give you
photographs of themselves and their
underwear and you put them on the
internet after 3 months if they don't
have their goals that will be the
fittest gym you have ever seen in your
life alright so the general rules of
behavioral change that I encourage you
to keep in mind you can make them very
complicated but looking at the data set
and the data sets that I have and we're
talking about thousands of people over
several years these these are the points
that I would remember number one is make
it conscious you have to be conscious of
decisions that you're making
subconsciously if you want to change
them so the flash diet which I mentioned
which has been studied at University of
Wisconsin it's been studying in London
is more effective than a food journal
and what's important to note is that
people who use food journals lose three
times as much weight as those who don't
that's a hell of a lot easier to take
photograph there's a good application
called diet snaps that you could use to
make it even easier before pictures so
if you look at the transformation
challenges the last 20 years
like the body for life challenge
typically rewarding million dollars
Lamborghini whatever it might be
the
I ate various the training berries the
winners almost always used before
photographs to make the pain painful
enough alright you don't have to make
those public you can put them on your
refrigerator your dog's forehead
wherever you'll see it frequently number
two is make it a game so Peter Drucker
has said very famous management the air
is what gets measured gets managed and I
would certainly agree with that five
sessions if you look at the Nike Plus
device what they found is to make a
behavior stick you have to log five
sessions it doesn't matter if they're
five minutes long or five hours long so
rigged the game so you can win if you're
going to go to the gym you want to make
that habit five sessions keep them
really short five to ten minutes doesn't
matter
lastly make it competitive like I
mentioned and then make it small and
temporary so not only the meed but a
two-week trial that's how I got my dad
started after you failed many other
diets in the past and last but not least
keep improvement relative so it's about
becoming the best you you can become in
the process creating data they can help
many other people it's not about being
the best in the world and in this case
the biggest guy in the world so keep a
relative small changes can have huge
impacts it doesn't have to be hard it
doesn't have to be complicated just take
it one step at a time and honest myth
mas wouldn't see the measurement and
objective I'll leave you with that thank
you
thank you guys for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what did you
think of this video what did you learn
from it what are you going to apply to
your body to start making a difference
leave it down in the comments I'm going
to join in the discussion thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
beans mm-hmm are you paleo paleo person
semi okay so the question was why why do
I recommend against consuming fruit for
the most part and why do I allow beans
on the slow carb diet so the first fruit
fruit as it existed 100 200 years ago is
very different from fruit as it exists
today it's it's selectively bred and
modified to have the highest level of
fructose or fruit sugar possible and
fructose is problematic for fat loss
specifically so if you're not trying to
lose fat I have no particular problem
with consuming fruit but if you want to
get the the best results possible from a
fat loss program fructose is concerted
converted to glycerol phosphate which is
then converted to body fat very very
efficiently it's like there's there's no
more efficient pathway you could find
just about same reason that high
fructose corn syrup will make you really
really fat another note same reason
agave nectar will make you very very fat
it's 90 percent concentrated fructose so
looking at from again from an from an
evolutionary standpoint the nutrient
necessity of fruit if you get it once a
week so I have the one day off the cheat
day or the binge day once per week on
this low-carb diet that's more than
enough to satisfy any sweet tooth
requirement as it relates to fruit if
you absolutely have to have fruit and
I'm experimenting with with with fruit
again in very moderate doses using
primarily berries because it does have a
fascinating effect on blood glucose it
flatlines your blood glucose so I do
recommend fruit on your off day having
it in the beginning of the day such as
grapefruit which also includes an ER
engine in which is interesting for
extending the half-life of caffeine but
when you implanted a Dexcom seven device
in my side it's a continuous glucose
monitor used by type 1 diabetics and I'm
planted in my side to track my blood
glucose 24/7 for about three weeks and
what I noticed is when you have this
small amount of fruit in the morning it
allows you to keep your your blood sugar
below
I think it's 100 nanograms per deciliter
milligrams per deciliter
it allows you to keep it below this
critical threshold for fat loss which is
pretty fascinating but in general I
would say just stay away from fruit from
what I've seen and I haven't seen any
deleterious health effects from that at
all
beans so beans if anyone here is a
strict paleo eater beans and legumes are
a big no-no for that same reason peanuts
are a big no-no and cashews I love
cashews but if you prepare beans
properly so if you're soaking them let's
say overnight I have just I simply
haven't seen the digestive issues that
one would expect based on how strongly
they are avoided on the Paleo diet I
haven't seen the problem so I I do
recommend lentils and and other legumes
and beans for the simple reason among
others that if people are only consuming
leafy vegetables or steamed vegetables
and protein they're almost always
hypocaloric and then they get irritable
they get headaches and they quit so that
would be that would be the main reason
and I'm convinced someday
I'll either be proven right or wrong as
I supposes the case with everything
lentils there's some property in lentils
that is just incorrect a force
multiplier for fat loss I cannot figure
out I don't know what it is I have my
speculations but lentils are amazing
tastes pretty good too so sleep my
opinions on sleep my opinions and sleep
depend on how many sessions of sleep you
get per day so most people in this room
will be familiar with what's called
monophasic sleep that's just go to bed
wake up you get one session of sleep if
you're doing that or speaking from a
personal basis if I'm doing that I like
to get 9 to 10 hours of sleep I sleep a
lot if on the other hand you're doing
what's called polyphasic sleep where you
break it up into multiple segments per
day and that can be taken to an extreme
and something called uberman which is I
believe two and a half hours of total
sleep per day which is comprised of
20-minute naps not terribly social as
you can imagine that can be sustained
and there's a lot of debate about this
there are long articles online about why
it's impossible I can't divulge it yet
but I can say right now I'm using some
along with a few other groups some
pretty sophisticated Emin straight that
it is possible
we're tracking people using EGS while
they sleep on uber map so it can be done
should you do it that's a separate
question for most people it's going to
be completely untenable and
unsustainable but there are people like
Matt Mullenweg usually called the lead
developer or one of the lead developers
of WordPress and while he was working on
WordPress he had his most productive
year of coding probably produced I'm
just speculating here but 60% of the
wordpress code in one year and he was
falling over man to most people if you
feel like you have to sleep 2 hours a
day to get more done I would say let's
let's look at the time management first
before we start cutting you back to two
hours but those would be my feelings so
as far as I can tell from the quick look
through the book it pretty much
concentrates on what we would normally
consider physical attributes do you have
any research or anything interesting on
minimum effective dose either for
balance and coordination because I
didn't see much there and also uh you
know mentally nootropics or you know
diet is as opposed to mental yeah good
good question so the have I found
anything for the minimum effective dose
for balance agility or mental
performance like no tropics so I was I
was as an undergrad first a neuroscience
major primarily because I wanted to
focus on smart drugs I've seen a lot
there are many different approaches you
can take
as far as balance goes there's quite a
lot of debate in the PT and athletic
training community about whether balance
is a general skill you can train just
like an if there exists of general
intelligence usually people would
segment it out into into for example
muscular symmetry so one of the fastest
ways to improve general agility and
balance I would say is by doing an
assessment called the FMS the functional
movement screen and I'm sure there are
people in SF who can do that and that
will assess
imbalances from left to right or cross
contralaterally and when you fix those
it's pretty astounding it's in the
prehab chapter but if you identify using
for example there's a movement called or
there two movements called the Chop and
lift we're using generally speaking a
cable and you're doing this type
chopping diagonal movement and then
you're reversing it and going up and so
you test your four quadrants and you'll
generally find that one quadrant is
extremely weak relatively speaking and
when you fix that it's incredible how
many aches and pains how many problems
how many injuries just disappear so I
would say that from a functional
standpoint that would be one if we're
talking about equilibrium I haven't
found anything to be particularly
effective for for general balance for
mental performance this is something
that I I really debated quite a lot
because I I'm a huge fan of cognitive
enhancement and I didn't improve I
didn't include any chapters specifically
on that because I found looking at the
literature that improving physical
performance what most people would
divorce from their mind or brain is
actually the best way to improve
cognitive performance and there's a
great book called spark which is written
by a Harvard MD about that looks at
physical education and some very
sophisticated programs for improving
academic performance specifically by
making students perform in a certain
heart rate immediately prior to their
worst subjects really fascinating stuff
but if we're talking about drugs I'm
sure there are a few people in this
audience who probably tried modafinil
among others so provigil which is an
anti narcoleptic anti narcolepsy drug
there are a lot of drugs that will
improve short-term memory working memory
reaction speed vasopressin which is an
antidiuretic hormone that's used in
let's say bedwetting and children in
some cases also can improve short-term
memory the reason that I have ended up
staying away from any of these drugs is
that I've realized in the course of
doing all this research and all this
testing that the brain is a very
sensitive instrument and the brain like
well the body likes homeostasis so if
you interrupt any of the feedback loops
you can cause some really significant
long-term problems that's certainly true
if you look at let's say anabolics use
if you're using super physiological high
dose let's just say testosterone Sippy
innate then you can screw up your HHH
PTA access and if you if you screw up
your hypothalamus boy you're you're
going to have a lot of issues so I've
ended up staying away from the smart
drugs most recently the exceptions would
be gear Beaumont 80 I love your Beaumont
a and it contains a handful of
stimulants that all have different
pharmacokinetics so you end up getting
this nice extended like three to four
hour buzz which is great for writing
among other things and the other I would
say for mental performance would be a
hunger so when you when you are in a
fasted state whether that's through
intermittent fasting or otherwise you
you will experience a heightened level
of cognitive function I think that does
reflect back to evolutionary from an
evolutionary standpoint if you're
hunting and gathering it's a good idea
to have better visual acuity if you're
really hungry and you need to find food
among other things but that's that's
somewhat speculation hopefully that
helps